[Música]
con un poco ya conocen seguramente a la
voz de ile con sus famosos temas que
empezó a contar adolescente al lado de
sus hermanos de Calle 13
que me prefieres compasiva desde
entonces la cantante y puertorriqueña se
ha hecho un nombre por sí misma con tres
álbumes como solista donde navega con
facilidad entre la balada el bolero y
los ritmos afrocaribeños sus letras la
revelan exploradora de las emociones
pero también comprometida con el
feminismo y el anticolonialismo nagarile
su último proyecto demuestra
definitivamente que ile está del lado de
los artistas cuya trayectoria tenemos
que seguir de cerca
Muchas gracias por compartir este
momento con nosotros en Franz 24 gracias
a ustedes se estrenó tu tercer álbum
nacaré en octubre del año pasado nos
puedes contar De dónde viene esta
expresión la caribe es un juego de
palabras es una expresión que usamos en
Puerto Rico la frase completa de
nacarile del oriente yo traté de Buscar
información y no hay mucha verdad como
que como del origen de decir esto pero
lo usamos normalmente cuando queremos
decir un no rotundo pero con mucha
actitud con mucha determinación este
como bien seguro entonces pues me
gustaba un poco ese contraste que tiene
una palabra que suena linda También
Macarena tiene ile particularmente
puesto ahí y al mismo tiempo pues es un
no motivador para mí
inacarré tu álbum no la expresión son 11
canciones entre ellas seis
colaboraciones es la mitad al final de
este disco con de Horizontes diferentes
Bueno hay mon laferte Natalia Lafourcade
que tiene un público que se cruza
seguramente con con el tuyo pero
invitaste también el español Rodrigo
Cuevas el argentino trueno cuéntanos el
hilo conductor que querías con este
álbum y con todas estas colaboraciones
Pues yo creo que eso fue como la parte
más difícil para mí con este disco está
el como todo el tiempo Pendiente al hilo
conductor y al concepto entonces este
tuve que hacerlo un poco de malabarismo
así porque era un año duro fue durante
ese proceso de la pandemia que fue como
bien abrumador y bien ajetreado y era
como difícil para mí se me hizo bien
difícil concentrarme en una sola cosa o
qué sé yo en un solo concepto y mi única
verdad mi única reacción fue como seguir
componiendo seguir escribiendo tratar de
no hacer tanto juicio de lo que estaba
trabajando y no achacarme demasiado
fluir un poco con lo que estaba saliendo
de ahí y porque dentro de todo me lo
estaba disfrutando solamente que estaba
como Esto va a funcionar va a tener
sentido como que no sabía si ese momento
iba a llegar y lo mismo con las
colaboraciones se fueron dando un poco
poquito a poco este y fue bien bonito yo
creo que quizás aunque fue caótico al
mismo tiempo ayudó un poco yo estar en
ese momento medio incómodo y eso me
permitió como simplemente
reaccionar y decir lo que yo creo que sí
vamos a hacerlo en vez de quizás darle
tanto pensamiento como suelo hacer la
mayoría de las veces
con tus palmas y tú haces que vuele me
acaricias con tus palmas y tú haces que
yo vuele
[Música]
loca porque
así
[Música]
lo que estaba entera y ahora estoy
volando encantos por
[Música]
ti y otra cosa que destaca de este
último último álbum es el trabajo todo
el trabajo de creación de videoclips de
visualizadores en YouTube para cada uno
de tus temas hay juegos de luz mucha
sensualidad era importante para ti
acompañar la experiencia del público con
este soporte visual que además es un
soporte visual súper creativo
Sí para mí o sea creo que con este disco
tuvo un poquito de más tiempo que con
los otros Y eso pues estuvo bueno porque
Don aumentó tuvo ese espacio no
solamente de poder escuchar y apreciar
más el disco
y como fluir un poco más en vez de ya
terminarlo entregarlo como que tuve un
poquito de espacio para procesarlo y así
mismo con los visuales como que aumentó
tuvo un poquito de tiempo para trabajar
los visuales si yo siento que este disco
es bastante abismal este
[Música]
por eso todos tienen como este contexto
un poco como de vacío como de infinito
también
y también no sé tiene algo como medio de
ensueño quizás Y eso pues me gustó a la
hora de trabajar los visuales creo que
pues al haber estado en un estado un
poquito medio dispersa y flotante cuando
trabaje el disco Pues creo que así mismo
se transmitieron los visuales y quién es
un vídeo en particular que te que te
encantó grabar o que el resultado
piensas Este sí lo hice bien o me parece
una maravilla bueno que cada cual ha
tenido una experiencia súper distinta o
sea
dirigí mi primer video en el escapándome
de mí que que para mí eso fue como una
experiencia súper yo nunca pensé que yo
iba a dirigir un video Fue un poco medio
de modo impulso este Porque nada
de hacerlo pero estaba súper asustada no
sabía por suerte tuve un equipo de
confianza y me sentí tranquila pero fue
súper loco o sea dirigir esta nunca lo
subestimé en mi vida pero como que
siempre estuve asustada pero me lancé y
fue fue linda la experiencia pero
también en los visuales el del que hice
de cuando te miro que es la canción Con
Rodrigo pues eso fue idea mía yo yo dije
Ah pues estaría chévere Yo como que no
se me llevó una soga pero de momento
como yo subir esa soga como que todo el
ejercicio que involucra Y tuvo una
preparación tuve que practiqué un poco
en un lugar que hay en Puerto Rico
Sí pero no no tuve tanto tiempo como que
fue como un día que fui a practicar y la
soga justo era bien gruesa y me raspó y
yo dije Olvídate o sea esto no me va a
salir pero yo bueno si no lo resolvemos
con otra cosa pero por suerte en el set
la soga era un po cuando éramos más
nueva entonces pues fluyó un poquito
mejor me tuve que poner el talco y todo
eso pero yo dije Ay qué bueno entonces
como quiera se me hizo difícil porque se
cansa o sea como que no es algo que yo
sé hacer pero pero era chévere creo que
iba con la canción Tú sabes la la
dificultad este desde subirla bajarla
caerse volver a subir este me iba con la
temática así que por lo menos había
espacio para fracasar un poquito
[Música]
todo parte
confunde y me congelas en tu hielo
[Música]
y bueno cuidar tanto la letra como lo
visual saber que los videoclips cuentan
y cuentan cosas es algo que compartes
con tus hermanos del grupo Calle 13
empezaste tu carrera musical con ellos
Qué mirada tienes sobre esta experiencia
Ahora que
tienes tres álbumes con un solista y que
bueno 2023
pues estoy como súper entusiasmada con
todo No no me quiero ilusionar más de la
cuenta verla como que no normalmente no
tiendo a tener mucha expectativa de las
cosas porque sé que puede surgir
cualquier cosa en el mundo
pero sí disfrutar Melo cada vez más yo
creo que el primer disco a este pues si
yo siento que me limitaba mucho yo misma
este me
quizás como que me exigía tanto Que de
momento no no sé si me llegaba a
disfrutar todo Como debería ser Pues
creo que con este disco al estar
batallando un poco conmigo misma con ese
tipo de cosas pues llegó un punto en que
rompí con todo eso y siento que eso me
ayudó ahora pues a estar un poquito más
verdad disfrutarme más los procesos
Incluyendo los momentos difíciles los
momentos de bloqueo y todas esas cosas
Pues nada reconocer que es parte de pero
seguir trabajando y para terminar esta
conversación con el tema justamente de
Puerto Rico estás acá en el hay festival
para grabar un episodio del podcast el
hilo frente a un público que además de
escucharte va a poder ver vídeos de ti
en las protestas del 2019 en Puerto Rico
eso muestra que tu imagen no se puede
separar ahora de esta lucha social que
tu voz cuenta que te piden tu visión te
piden hablar de estas protestas cómo te
sientes con esto puede para mí o sea yo
siempre siento que es súper importante
seguir regando la voz un poco de la
situación que pasaba en Puerto Rico
también yo creo que hace unos años había
mucha gente que desconocía de la
existencia de Puerto Rico o sea como que
no no sabían que existía una isla
llamada Puerto Rico y la gente que sabía
Pues conocía muy poco inclusive pues
Nosotros siempre estamos muy
acostumbrados a que la gente no
conociera sobre el país Entonces ahora
pues me parece súper bello que que esté
un poco más en la conversación que Que
de momento pues sintamos más esa
solidaridad esa conexión esa hermandad
con otros países y que nos apoyemos nos
acompañemos un poquito más porque sí a
veces Pues cuando eres de una isla te
sientes aislado un poco de del resto del
mundo y pues que se sigue expandiendo
esta conversación aunque sean
situaciones un poco duras pero yo creo
que nos ayuda a entendernos un poquito
mejor y a que y a que nos dé fuerza
también para seguir en la lucha pues
muchas gracias
igualmente
[Música]
ellos sin ti mi vida
cuando llegue ese momento
de ponerlo de rodillas
se intimidad
ellos se intimida
cuando llegue ese momento
de ponerlo de rodillas
[Música]